today I'm going to share some really
important information on how to get rid
of your belly fat the easiest way
possible and primarily the exercise you
need to focus on I've talked about the
contribution of exercise to belly fat
loss being about 15 and diet being 85
percent but the question is what type of
exercise would be the best exercise to
help you lose this belly fat so I do
want to share some new information on
this topic that I stumbled on on a
research paper that involved 54
different studies number one they're
operating off this information on
calories in their mind they think that
body fat equals calories in versus
calories out so the lower amount of
calories they intake the greater the
body fat this is known as the energy
balance equation which has been proven
false so many times so I have a question
for you if you lower your dietary
calories
what happens to the rate at which you
burn those calories well unfortunately
it adapts it adjusts to your calories so
as soon as you start lowering your
calories let's say for example you lower
your calories by 20 right well guess
what happens to your metabolic rate it
too lowers by about 20 percent now I'm
not saying that calories don't matter
because obviously if you cut down your
calories low enough you will eventually
lose weight in fact if you don't eat
you're going to lose weight but the
question is is it sustainable can you do
it for how long eventually you're going
to need to eat and let's say you do lose
your weight and heat your goal then what
do you keep doing the same thing over
and over again how do you maintain this
weight and the other question is are all
calories fattening and the answer is no
you have to look at calories from the
Viewpoint of how your hormones influence
these calories the next problem is
something called the set point so let's
say you lose weight right and you go go
on a diet and you lose the weight and
for some reason you can't seem to get
below a certain weight let's say it's
155 pounds no matter what your body will
not go below that regardless of what you
do effort being put out exercise dieting
you tend to lose weight but not below a
certain point that is a person's
individual set point and unfortunately
too much dieting can raise that set
point up to the point where every time
you start another diet you become
further and further away from your goal
and then we have the problem of exercise
what is the best exercise that will
maximize and be the best strategy to
leverage the maximum fat loss from your
midsection if you end up doing the wrong
exercise it can be devastating you're
going into the gym week after week just
spinning your wheels not really getting
anywhere so before we get into the first
exercise that we need to get you into
the most important thing that you need
to know is that we have to first switch
your body to burn fat okay as your
primary fuel source there are two fuel
sources one is sugar the other is fat
and so many people end up mistakingly
just burning sugar Fuel and their body
is running off the calories of the meal
that they just ate and so they never
have a chance to tap into their actual
fat we want the body to run on fat not
just when you're sleeping but between
your meals as well and whether you burn
sugar or fat really depends on one
hormone and that is called insulin if
insulin goes up you will not burn fat
you're only going to burn sugar if it
goes down your body will then burn fat
you have to realize that the fat on your
body is a survival mechanism and it's
very unnatural for your body to actually
burn fat in the first place it doesn't
like burning off this fat it likes to
retain fat especially in your midsection
but you can Leverage urge certain pieces
of knowledge to get your body in fat
burning by simply understanding the
hormone influence over certain calories
so if we take the type of calories you
have carbohydrate calories you have
protein calories and you have fat
calories so out of all three of those
type of calories there's really only one
type of calorie that increases insulin
believe it or not the fat calories do
not influence insulin of any significant
degree but on the flip side it doesn't
mean that you can just start eating
unlimited amounts of fat and lose the
weight that's not going to happen if you
lower the very specific type of calorie
cold carbohydrates your body will then
be forced to burn fat Fuel and from that
fat fuel you will also develop a more
available type of energy called ketones
okay so ketones are the byproduct of fat
the energy that your body can use as
fuel so to get your body of fat burning
we need to lower insulin by number one
lowering your carbohydrates and number
two and this is actually more important
okay
lower the number of meals that you eat
okay eat less frequently this is called
intermittent fasting so I had a friend
who did the ketogenic diet right and uh
he said it doesn't work and I said what
are you doing well I went on low carb
right I'm eating all this fat and I'm
eating all these keto fat bombs which
are these cookies made out of fat and
I'm eating them all day and I'm actually
gaining weight so obviously you missed
the other key component which is
intermittent fasting it's necessary
because of this very important
information that a lot of people don't
understand so if you've checked out I
want you to check back in right now
because this is very very very important
in addition to the carbohydrate
increasing insulin eating in general
will increase insulin so that little
snack that you had eating between meals
is very very very bad so to make this
successful you must not only lower your
carbs you must eat less frequently this
is called intermittent fasting you want
to do them together if you do that
you'll get in the fat burning and
between the meals and at night you will
be burning fat fuel so you'll be eating
your own fat between the meals and
what's really cool about that is that
your appetite goes away you will not be
hungry between the meals which will make
it very easy to do long term plus you
won't have cravings versus the other way
it's going to be torture because you're
going to be
hungry you're going to want to eat every
hour and a half you're going to want a
snack it's disastrous now there's one
more thing that you need to know and
this is another really really important
piece of information when you start
adapting into this fat burning or
ketones it takes about two days well if
you eat a tiny amount of carbohydrate
calories guess what can happen that
piece of bread or half a glass of wine
can literally pause this whole program
and stop fat burning for two freaking
days so this could be very very
depressing especially if you're doing
mostly good but you just have a little
bit of certain things
too frequent like every other day and so
the second most important thing you need
to know is consistency okay staying very
very consistent with this program this
means doing it a hundred percent it if
you do this consistently your body is
going to get in this very interesting
State called the fat adapted state where
your body is very very efficiently now a
fat burning machine this is very
important because if you get into this
state which by the way does take some
time it can take up to a month to get
into the state it's going to correct
something called insulin resistance
which most people have and it is the
real root cause behind stubborn weight
especially in your midsection so you're
going to actually correct a bad
metabolism or a slow metabolism by
getting into this fat adapted state but
to do that you have to be consistent
correcting insulin resistance is going
to be huge because now things are going
to get easier and easier so then when we
add the exercise which is the next point
it's finally going to be something that
really works for you as a side note
since we're talking about in insulin
resistance there's a couple other things
that you can do very simply just add one
tablespoon of apple cider vinegar to
your water and drink that two or even
three times a day put one tablespoon and
then drink that with the straw apple
cider vinegar greatly improves this
insulin resistance that one little tiny
change can actually create a big effect
on not just your weight but if you have
any liver fat it can help reduce fat off
your liver it can help balance your
blood sugars number three let's talk
about the exercise and this is based on
the study which I'm going to put down
below but it's not really just one study
it's just a kind of like a a review of
54 different studies on this one topic
which we're going to call walking
walking actually can help you burn more
fat off your midsection than doing this
higher intense exercise but I need to
explain the details of this I'm not
saying not to do high intense exercise
but you're going to get more benefit out
of doing walking than the higher
intensity type exercise even though I do
recommend doing high intensity interval
training okay with the walking
but the high intensity interval training
tends to improve certain hormones it
tends to spike growth hormone
testosterone it's essential for growing
muscle but as far as fat burning you're
going to be more successful
from the walking now when you walk
you're doing a type of exercise that is
lower intensity okay and the first 30
minutes you're going to burn up kind of
the stored sugar in your body that's
called glycogen and then after 30
minutes you are going to be burning pure
fat so obviously we want you to walk at
least an hour maybe even more than that
up to two hours per day now I'm just
talking about going for a walk I'm not
even counting all the other steps that
you're walking through the day which
could add up to a lot but typically
walking only really burns like 200 to
300 calories per hour and that doesn't
seem like a lot but when you are walking
you are reducing cortisol which is
stress you're clearing out cortisol and
adrenaline which is a huge barrier to
losing weight walking greatly
significantly improves insulin
resistance and I highly recommend that
you get a pedometer to measure how many
steps that you walk in a day because you
want to increase those steps to around 8
000 to 10 000 steps per day here's a
number of ideas that you can do to
actually increase more walking through
the day number one take your dog on a
walk go on a walk with a friend usually
that can help motivate you and push you
to walk more when you walk try to speed
up a little bit more so you're not
walking too slowly if you have a chance
to take uh the stairs or walk up a hill
take advantage of that when you walk try
to find something in nature that you can
actually you know look at and get your
attention out and look at things that
will accelerate the process because
you're improving What's called the
parasympathetic nervous system which is
all about reducing stress versus just
kind of getting on a treadmill and
watching some screen or your cell phone
which you're not having a chance to get
more space by looking around you in your
environment make a game out of it make
it fun don't get too serious about it
start recording your numbers and each
time try to build on that and getting a
little bit more if it's raining outside
you know walk in your house what what I
do is I can kind of walk downstairs
upstairs walk downstairs upstairs walk
around the rooms come around
I've done that in the winter when it was
snowing and because I go I couldn't go
outside it's not a bad idea to also walk
after you eat with each meal especially
if you feel bloated or you have
digestive problems walking can greatly
improve that now I want to tell you a
recent experience that I just went
through that I think you'll find very
interesting I decided to do what's
called stem cell therapy okay and stem
cell therapy is where they take some of
your fat okay and then they siphon it
down pull the stem cells out put it into
a vial inject it back into your body to
help circulate and heal certain things
and I did it mainly for old injuries and
arthritis that I have in my spine so
I've been looking at this for a long
time and I decided to bite the bullet
and get it done but they have to do
liposuction and when they evaluated me I
didn't have enough fat so I had to gain
more fat around my midsection so they
can can lipo it out and have enough fat
I needed five pounds more fat in my
midsection now that might not seem like
a lot but it's a lot in order to gain
five pounds of fat I had to gain more
weight than that right because you don't
just gain fat you gain some muscle and
fat so I basically went from 183 pounds
to 197 pounds now the question is how
did I gain this fat number one I ate
more carbs but I didn't eat like the
Breads and pasta and cereal and crackers
and stuff like that okay because that
creates a bit more inflammation
I had things like certain fruits like
apples with peanut butter between the
meals especially I had things like
blueberries and I'm talking a lot of
blueberries I even ate things like
potatoes but I had the purple potatoes
from the Peruvian potatoes that had more
antioxidants and I also had some red
potatoes and I ate more calories for
sure and I also ate three meals plus
snacks and I gained a good amount of fat
in my midsection so I live on a farm and
there's nothing flat there's all sorts
of hills
and I'm very used to walking everywhere
all day long and what I noticed when I
started to try to gain weight I wasn't
gaining any weight because I was walking
all over burning all these calories so
what I basically had to do is slow down
not walk around so much and that was
very hard to do but it was a really key
thing to help me gain weight so after
the procedure I'm back on my original
program I'm doing two meals a day okay
I'm not doing potatoes anymore I'm not
doing any more fruit especially the
apples and then we'll create a video on
the stem cell uh therapy and the results
of that in about a month because it does
take some time for it to work now that
you have these principles the next thing
you need to know is the details of
exactly what to eat and for that
information you should check this video
out right here